this morning our series of dishes
focusing on a condiment that is strong
in flavor and tradition chili crisp has
a long history in china but now its
popularity is blooming around the world
including right here in this country
leading bran la gun mao is inspiring new
chefs to put their own spin on the
topping think of something that could go
on pizza
um pizza dumplings and ice cream how
does that work nancy chen met one chef
who adds her signature chili crisp to
just about everything you can think of
crunchy and textured i love that sizzle
a bright collision of chilies and spices
simmered in oil smells really good
chinese chili crisp isn't spicy hot but
the condiment is on fire
long ladled onto classic asian dishes
like dumplings noodles and stir fries
chili crisp is exploding in popularity
even expanding to the desert menu
is there anything you can't put it on i
have yet to find something you can't put
it on if it's edible you can put it on
chef and fly by jing ceo jin gao at her
unique spin to the traditional topping
by sourcing 18 ingredients exclusively
from her hometown in citroen china red
chilies that are
fruity
mild heat super fragrant the high
quality ingredients from chengdu
including sichuan pepper and fermented
black beans aren't readily available
elsewhere but gao gave us an idea how
they all come together in her los
angeles kitchen what is the appeal here
is it the spiciness the texture there's
something about it you can't really put
your finger on but somehow it just works
with everything right it is basically
just the components of chilies and oil
but when you add in those extra layers
that's what gives the chili crisp the
extra dimension of flavor and now the
flavors are infused into the oil
families in china have enjoyed their own
time-honored recipes that's mappu tofu
right there yes
but it became widely commercialized when
a chinese noodle maker bottled and
branded her version lagen ma now
produces more than a million jars a day
for fans in more than 30 countries we're
playing a part in preserving that
tradition by pushing it forward by
introducing it to new audiences a
culture and a tradition if it doesn't
evolve it dies so we want to play a part
in evolving it in our own way after
leaving her tech industry job gao opened
a restaurant in shanghai focused on
locally sourced ingredients before
traveling the world as a chef in pop-up
kitchens for
a very long time people had not just a
lack of awareness about what chinese
cuisine was but also
additional bias against it like that
it's
oily that is oily that it's unhealthy
that it's low quality and should be
cheap
right and so if those are the attitudes
that people have towards chinese cuisine
then there's no incentive for anybody to
really bring anything of quality out
it's about more than just the food too
when you talk about those perceptions
absolutely in 2018 gal launched a viral
kickstarter campaign to fund her own
signature chili crisp
and with more people cooking at home
during the pandemic her company has
grown tenfold churning out nearly a
million jars in the past year
the u.s chile crisp craze isn't limited
to store shelves and kitchen counters
restaurants are also making it their own
that's two really good things together
famed brooklyn pizza maker paulie g
recently partnered with family run she
and famous foods for a pie centered
around their secret recipe made up of
three fragrant spices this is xi'an
famous pizza what do the chili crisps
add to this
texture
even with more than 50 pizzas on the
menu g says this one quickly became a
hit after its debut
we're eating
pizza that's made out of an oven that
came from italy and it's using spice
that is inspired by something that
people in china have been eating for
centuries and it's all made here in
america
our goal is to
change the conversation about chinese
food to
elevate its status in our culture so
we're really here to
[Music]
uplift all marginalized cultures not
just chinese and we're doing so through
flavor a melting pot of taste melding
together tradition and innovation i have
made a version of a mezcal paloma
there's a rim of mala spice oh and then
a little bit of the chili crisp oil
well cheers cheers
cheers to you too nancy chen it's not
even 9am and i already want pizza
and guess what i'm gonna have me some
pizza today i'm thinking some dumplings
myself i got the cocktails but i can't
confirm that chili crisp is terrific on
vanilla ice cream yeah you've tried it
as well no we did
and you can actually make it at home
i've made chili crisp at home it
involves usually water scratch yeah well
not from scratch i mean i buy the
ingredients and make it what does
scratch really mean i'm not getting the
buying the ingredients and making okay
yeah i buy the ingredients it usually
has one tricky ingredient like star
anise or anise how do you say that i've
we say anise in our house but who am i
to
but it's worth it is what i'm saying
it's very good stuff yeah how
complicated is it uh you know use the
heat dump it all in a couple there's an
order you follow it's like dancing which
i can't do so actually it's very
complicated
notice john that he looked at you to say
how do you say a niece or anas because
you know looking over here i'm like
well we'll be getting
we'll be getting some responses if i was
wrong yes yes